as you might have heard there are people
peacefully protesting at the supreme
court now when i use the term peacefully
protesting i actually mean it i'm not
referring to the trump riots of january
6th which were extraordinarily violent
and criminal and saying it was a
peaceful protest i'm actually talking
about just peaceful protest protected by
the first amendment with permits even
permits for the speech
and yesterday florida of republican
governor ron desantis was in new york
and he said that those protesters at the
supreme court are engaging in an
insurrection and this is something we've
seen many times from republicans when
they do a thing
they start saying uh it is the left who
is actually doing that thing
when a word starts to be part of the
milieu
uh
they start to use the word and try to
redefine it or change it which is funny
because it's what they accuse the left
of doing oh the left is trying to
redefine woman
the left is trying to read this
right but now you're saying that just a
protest is an insurrection because you
don't like the fact that your side did a
horrible riotous insurrection attempt on
january 6th of 2021 so let's look at
what ron de santa said not sounding i
will say like the biggest supporter of
the first amendment here what they're
trying to bring
is attention to the fact that the
supreme court may overturn roe v wade
later today or then again the coverage
could come out
next week when they uh ultimately do
issue their opinion
well i think that we have a rule of law
in this country and you don't get to
just have a mob descend on a supreme
court justice's house or try to impede
the operations of government because
there may be a decision you don't like
that would be considered an insurrection
to stop a court from functioning and yet
they seem to be able to get away with a
lot more uh than if the shoe were on the
other foot so okay so listen we we have
to break these things down one by one
first and foremost
the armed person who went to kavanaugh's
house
absolutely outrageous
seemingly criminal
arrest them charge them throw the book
at him 100
in terms of the protests in general at
the judges at the justices houses i've
already said it is for law enforcement
and the justice department to figure out
when is it legal and when is it not
there are elements of that that are
absolutely protected by free speech
and there are elements of it that may go
over and it has to do with the specifics
of where the protest is taking place etc
but the protesters at the supreme court
are not trying to shut down the supreme
court they are making their voices heard
and it is a permitted peaceful protest a
real permitted peaceful protest unlike
what happened on january 6th and uh
think of the absurdity right i mean on
the one hand they want us to believe
january 6th was fine
uh despite the fact that there were vi
there was violence there were people
entering the building there were people
chanting to hang the vice president
there were people stealing stuff there
were people breaking windows that was
nothing that was fine it was peaceful it
was tourists it was whatever on the
other hand the current supreme court
protests no violence
they have permits
they're not entering the building
they're not chanting to hang anyone
they're not stealing stuff they're not
breaking windows
that we're supposed to believe is an
insurrection and of course hopefully the
interviewer would point that out and ask
a follow-up question but at the end of
the day it is fox news by the way there
they haven't even built gallows to hang
anyone at the supreme court protests
which is a an interesting notable thing
so the real concern here is i mean
listen desantis is a clown but the real
concern is
if these people get power back in
november in the house and or senate
which they may
if desantis becomes the next president i
mean i know it's early but he's doing
really well in 2024 primary polling and
he's not even running
um and he's less incompetent than trump
it's not inconceivable that he could
become president
if these people get power and they may
get it back soon
what does it actually mean for peace for
real peaceful protest what does it mean
for criticism of the government or
whatever the case may be
extraordinarily scary and dystopian
stuff